un gran error Así es como Joe biden
describe la suspensión por parte de
Rusia de su participación en el tratado
de reducción de armas nucleares en el
segundo día de su visita a Polonia el
presidente estadounidense reaccionó al
anuncio hecho por Vladimir Putin el día
anterior pero su discurso tenía como
principal objetivo tranquilizar a los
dirigentes del grupo de los nueve de
bucarest con los que se reúne Bulgaria
República Checa Estonia Hungría letonia
lituania Polonia Rumanía y Eslovaquia
para estos miembros de la otan el
mensaje es claro el gran hermano
norteamericano cuenta con cada uno de
los integrantes y los apoyará contra La
amenaza rusa
como flanco oriental de la otan ustedes
son la primera línea de nuestra defensa
colectiva Y saben mejor que nadie lo que
está en juego en este conflicto no solo
para Ucrania sino también para la
libertad de la democracia en Europa y en
el mundo el compromiso de Estados Unidos
con la otan se lo he dicho muchas veces
se lo repito es absolutamente claro el
artículo cinco es un compromiso
fundamental Estados Unidos nosotros cada
centímetro de la otan cada centímetro
Cómo mantener el bloque Unido cuando
algunos de estos países centro europeos
como Hungría y Bulgaria están divididos
por disputas sobre la cuestión del apoyo
a Ucrania para el presidente
estadounidense y el secretario de la
otan son los más convencidos al momento
de tomar la palabra
nosotros los dirigentes del frente
Oriental tenemos el deber de mantenernos
firmes en defensa de nuestra Paz debemos
seguir firmes en nuestro compromiso de
apoyar a Ucrania todo el tiempo que
necesite para ganar esta guerra
tras una parada sorpresa a la capital
ucraniana del lunes y dos días en
Polonia Joe biden mostró su
determinación de consolidar El bando
occidental contra el kremlin para los
ucranianos presentes frente al palacio
presidencial de Varsovia Estados Unidos
debe aumentar su apoyo en particular
enviando aviones de com